Hi there everyone, and welcome back to
the channel. I'm in the middle of
testing a huge batch of ESCs, but I had
to stop to make this video because I saw
something terrifying.
The legs of this capacitor are not just
warm, they're hot enough to melt solder.
And if we swap to a different capacitor,
exactly the same ESC and exactly the
same test, these legs stay cool as a
cucumber.
In this video, I'm going to take you
through why low ESR on a capacitor is
often a lie,
what different types of capacitor there
are that we use on drones, and which
capacitors you need to buy and which you
need to throw away to make sure that
your drone doesn't fall out of the sky.
It's a lot to cover in one video, so
let's not waste any more time. Let's
dive right into it.
In the past, when I've selected
capacitors for my drones, I've often
focused on the specs. How many
microfarads? What's the voltage rating?
And how physically big is the capacitor?
Am I going to be able to fit it in my
build?
But when I've been recording ESCs with a
thermal camera under testing, I've seen
that the legs or leads of the capacitor
are often the critical bottleneck.
But why would the leads of these two
seemingly identical capacitors perform
completely differently? They're the same
length, the same thickness, and they
look identical.
But there is a hidden variable that will
see one of these capacitors outlast the
life of the drone, while the other one
melts like a fuse the first time you
punch out. And that variable is the
material that the legs are made from.
I've always assumed that the legs or
leads of a capacitor are made from
nickel-plated copper wire, a solid
copper core with a thin coating of
nickel for corrosion resistance and to
make it easy to solder, just like every
other wire on our drones.
But that couldn't be further from the
truth. Most capacitor leads are made of
copper-clad steel, a steel wire plated
with copper and then plated with nickel
over the top for corrosion resistance
and solderability.
At high currents, these steel leads can
act like toaster wires and get super
hot.
The capacitors we solder to our ESCs are
subjected to incredible abuse.
At mid-throttle, we're switching power
to the motor phases thousands of times
every second, and every time those FETs
switch on or off, there is a rush of
current either into or out of the
capacitor.
All of that current has to flow through
the capacitor leads, and that generates
resistive heating via the I squared R
rule. Obviously, the higher the
resistance of the lead, the more heat is
generated by the current flowing into or
out of the capacitor.
But, it's worse than that because that I
squared R heating heats up the leg of
the capacitor, and the higher the
temperature, the higher the resistivity.
So, it's quite easy to get a thermal
runaway effect, whereby the resistivity
climbs with temperature, which means
that more heat is generated, which means
that the temperature climbs even
further, until the capacitor lead gets
so hot that it melts and separates from
the ESC.
The moment that lead melts, the
capacitor is no longer connected to the
ESC, and that means there is nowhere for
that surge of current to go. And so, it
creates enormous voltage spikes, which
is often enough to blow up the FETs, TVS
diode, or voltage regulator on the ESC,
and any of those failing will cause your
drone to immediately fall out of the
sky.
So, now we understand the problem, but
that doesn't explain why some capacitor
legs get hot enough to melt steel,
whilst others stay pretty cool even
under the most extreme loads.
The answer is that not all copper-clad
steel is created equal. There are
different grades with vastly different
electrical properties.
The resistivity of copper-clad steel is
graded using the IACS, the International
Annealed Copper Standard.
This compares the resistance of a
copper-clad steel wire to a pure copper
wire of the same length and diameter.
If the resistance is the same, that has
an IACS rating of 100%.
If, however, the copper-clad steel wire
has twice the resistance of the copper
wire, then that has an IACS rating of
50%.
Standard cheap copper-clad steel wire
has an IACS rating of about 20%. That
makes it five times the resistance of a
copper wire of the same length and
diameter.
But, it depends on grade. You can get
higher-grade, more expensive copper-clad
steel wire with IACS ratings of 30 or
even 40%.
The difference is just the thickness of
the copper coating on the steel wire.
The more copper you plate onto the
steel, the lower the resistance of the
copper-clad steel wire overall, and the
higher the IACS grade.
As you can imagine, cheaper unbranded
capacitors, even if they're marked low
ESR, are going to be using the cheaper
grades of copper-clad steel with a
resistance of 20% IACS.
This resistance is simply too high for a
drone application. We are pushing too
much current through the leads. They are
going to get super hot and potentially
melt. Unfortunately, it's very difficult
to determine what grade of copper-clad
steel a particular manufacturer is using
when they make a capacitor. Both 20% and
40% IACS respond similarly to a magnetic
field. They have similar strength,
similar stiffness. It really comes down
just to the conductivity, which is very
hard to measure for a capacitor lead
that's very short and relatively
conductive. Unless you happen to have a
thermal camera pointed at the capacitor
legs while you're driving a motor, it's
really difficult to determine if you've
got one of the good ones or if your
capacitor is a ticking time bomb just
waiting to make your drone fall out of
the sky.
Don't worry, at the end of this video,
I'm going to give you some clear
recommendations of particular brands and
models of capacitor so that you can
avoid this lead melting issue.
But, the leads melting is not the only
way that I have seen capacitors fail
during this ESC testing. There are other
much more catastrophic failure modes and
we need to understand these in order to
get a full picture of capacitor
durability.
We use two different types of capacitors
on our ESCs, wet electrolytic and solid
polymer.
These two different types have very
different constructions, performance,
and durability.
Wet electrolytic capacitors are
constructed of an aluminum foil anode
coated in a thin layer of aluminum oxide
which acts as a dielectric that
separates the positive and negative
sides of the capacitor.
The cathode of the capacitor is
constructed of a paper soaked in a
liquid electrolyte. And when we push
current into or draw current out of the
capacitor, that current has to flow as
ions within the liquid and that has a
significant ESR or equivalent series
resistance. Those ions have to bump
their way past the liquid molecules and
that limits how fast current can flow
into or out of a wet electrolytic
capacitor.
Low ESR electrolytic caps have
specialized liquid electrolytes that
have maximum ion motility so that the
ions can move quickly through the liquid
to allow them to charge and discharge
quickly and to reduce their equivalent
series resistance or ESR.
If we have a capacitor with an ESR
that's too high, even if the leads are
nice and conductive, the current flowing
into and out of the capacitor will heat
it up significantly over time. And if
the capacitor gets too hot, that liquid
electrolyte is going to boil and cause
the capacitor to explode. Solid polymer
capacitors have a very different
construction. They share the same
aluminum foil anode and aluminum oxide
dielectric as wet electrolytic
capacitors,
but the cathode is composed of a solid
polymer that is polymerized and grown
onto the foil during manufacturing.
This solid polymer carries electric
charge into and out of the capacitor as
electrons jumping along conductive
polymer chains. And electrons moving
through a solid in this way is
enormously easier and more efficient
than ions bumping through a liquid.
The result is that a solid polymer
capacitor can have an ESR of 1,000 to
10,000 times lower than a wet
electrolytic capacitor.
This lower equivalent series resistance
means that we can push much more current
into and out of a solid polymer
capacitor before it starts to
significantly heat up internally.
Solid polymer capacitors have another
advantage, and that is that they
maintain their capacitance at high
frequencies much better than wet
electrolytic capacitors.
This is because the aluminum foil inside
the capacitor is etched with microscopic
pits and tunnels to increase its surface
area.
In a wet electrolytic capacitor, the
ions have a very hard time bumping their
way through the liquid and getting into
those tunnels and pits to access all of
that surface area. It takes a while for
the ions to move down those tunnels.
At low frequencies, that's fine. The
ions have plenty of time to get down the
tunnels and access the whole surface
area of the foil.
But at high frequencies, they simply
don't have time to move that distance.
And so the ions only access the surface
of the foil. They don't get deep into
those tunnels and pits. That means that
a wet electrolytic capacitor can lose
anywhere from 20% to 50% of its
effective capacitance at 48 kilohertz,
for example.
Normally, a capacitor is measured at
about 120 hertz, but we are switching
these capacitors at 24 kilohertz or 48
kilohertz. And that is a much, much
higher frequency, and so we see a
significant loss of capacitance with a
wet electrolytic type. Because solid
polymer capacitors have a much more
conductive cathode, the electrons can
zip down those polymer chains into the
tunnels and the pits really, really
quickly and access all of that surface
area even at high frequency. This means
that a solid polymer capacitor maintains
its capacitance much, much better. And
that means under use in an ESC, a 470
microfarad solid polymer capacitor might
have more effective capacitance than a
1,000 microfarad wet electrolytic.
Does this mean that we should all switch
to using solid polymer capacitors for
our future drone builds?
Well, not necessarily because there is
one final trade-off that you need to be
aware of when comparing solid polymer
and wet electrolytic. And that is
durability to voltage spikes.
When either of these types of capacitor
is exposed to a voltage spike above its
maximum voltage rating, it can cause a
localized breakdown of that thin
aluminum oxide layer between the anode
and the cathode.
As that aluminum oxide layer breaks
down, it allows current to flow from the
anode to the cathode and actually shorts
out the capacitor.
In a wet electrolytic type capacitor,
the electrolyte reacts with the exposed
aluminum layer to regrow that aluminum
oxide and heal the damage from the
spike. Provided that the damage is not
too severe, the capacitor can continue
operating with very, very little loss of
performance.
If, however, the damage is more severe
in a wet electrolytic capacitor, the
heat generated from the current flowing
from the anode to the cathode will boil
away the electrolyte and effectively
render the capacitor an open circuit.
In a solid polymer capacitor, there is
no electrolyte to react with the exposed
aluminum layer, so that aluminum oxide
dielectric cannot regrow.
That means that a solid polymer
capacitor cannot self-heal. And worse
than that, if current starts flowing
from the anode to the cathode, the heat
generated can melt the solid polymer.
It actually continues to conduct
electricity and the whole capacitor will
fail, short circuit, get incredibly hot,
and explode.
This means that solid polymer capacitors
are little bit more fragile at the same
maximum voltage rating compared to wet
electrolytics.
This brings us to the recommendations.
What capacitors should you use on your
future drone builds, and which should
you consign to e-waste if you ever get
given them alongside an ESC?
Before we dive into what brand, what
type, and what series of capacitor to
buy for your drone, we first need to
identify the correct maximum voltage
rating for the cap and the capacitance.
And for capacitor voltage rating, I have
a rule of thumb, which is that your
capacitor voltage rating should be 1.5
to two times your maximum battery
voltage. If you have a smaller drone or
your drone is more for cruising, then
1.5 times maximum battery voltage is
probably okay.
If you have a bigger drone with bigger
motors and you are flying more
aggressively or you want extra
durability in case you crash and a prop
gets stuck in a tree and creates a big
voltage spike, then you could go up to
two times the maximum battery voltage.
That should give you plenty of overhead
to make sure that your voltage spikes
don't ever exceed your capacitor voltage
rating.
The amount of capacitance you need on
your drone depends more on the prop
diameter than the battery voltage.
If you're flying a small drone with
props up to 2.5 in,
then a 220 microfarad capacitor is
probably going to be plenty. And if
you're prioritizing small form factor,
lightweight, and maximum performance, I
would look for a solid polymer or
ideally a hybrid polymer type. A hybrid
polymer is just a solid polymer
capacitor with a tiny drop of liquid
electrolyte in it to help it self-heal
from any voltage spikes and improve
durability. So, it's kind of the best of
both worlds.
If you're going up to a 4-in prop, then
you're probably going to want to
increase to a 330 to 470 mic capacitor.
And again, prioritize that hybrid
polymer type to give you the best
possible durability, especially if
you're running 4 or even 6S.
When we get up to 5-in, then you again
need to go up in size. And here, I would
look for between a 680 to 1,000
microfarad if you're using a wet
electrolytic type, or you can go to a
470 mic to 680 mic hybrid polymer.
I'm going to go against iFlight here and
actually not recommend a solid polymer
for 5-in builds because they're a little
bit brittle against voltage spikes, and
I have seen some fail in my ESC testing.
A hybrid polymer is going to give you a
lot more durability, particularly if
you're running 6S. If you're running 4S,
then a 35-V solid polymer is probably
plenty. But for 6S, I would definitely
go with a 35-V hybrid.
As we get up to bigger drones, you're
not going to be able to find solid
polymer or hybrid polymer capacitors in
a large enough capacity with a high
enough voltage rating to really be
practical for these builds. So, we're
going to be using low ESR wet
electrolytic type caps with a 1,000 to
2,000 microfarad rating for 7-in going
up to at least 2,000 for 8-10 in and at
least 3,000 for props over 10 in. For
these larger drones where you need
2,000, 3,000, even 4,000 microfarads of
capacitance, it's not going to be
practical and I wouldn't recommend using
a single capacitor with that rating.
It's much better to use multiple smaller
capacitors in parallel because that is
going to be easier to fit in your build,
it's going to be more durable, and it
also reduces the ESR of the capacitors
so that they actually filter spikes from
the motors even better.
If you have a large ESC, it will often
come with a bank of capacitors on little
PCB, or you're going to have multiple
points around the ESC where you can
solder capacitors. Make use of those and
try and use as many capacitors as
possible to get up to your rating. So,
if you're trying to get to at least
3,000 microfarads,
try four 1,000 microfarad capacitors in
parallel. Then that's going to give you
a quarter of the ESR of a single 1,000
microfarad capacitor and it's going to
be much, much better filtering those
spikes.
Here is my buying guide for FPV
capacitors. And we're going to start
with the wet electrolytic type which are
durable and cheap.
You can screenshot this slide so that
you can look through the capacitors you
already have and match them up with the
ones I recommend from this list.
But if you're buying new capacitors for
an FPV drone, I would stick to either
Panasonic or Rubicon.
The FR series is the one that I would
generally recommend in this wet
electrolytic category because it's
modern, it's small, and it's very
durable.
If you're just after maximum
performance, the FM series is also good,
but those capacitors are physically
larger and they don't have quite as long
a service life.
Rubicon makes some great capacitors as
well. The ZLJ and the ZLH are
particularly good and those are the ones
I would recommend. But the FS and ZLQ
series are really useful if you are
building a really tight build and you
need the maximum capacitance in the
smallest space. They don't quite have
the same ripple current capacity, but
it's still pretty good and they are
physically a little bit more compact.
These are the capacitors you should
definitely avoid. Do not buy them and do
not use them even if they come provided
with your ESC.
JWCO, Chong X or Cheng X and CapXon are
all cheaper brands that are perfectly
suitable for budget electronics but are
not up to the kind of abuse that we give
them with our ESCs. They have cheaper
lower grade copper clad steel legs that
have a high resistance and get super hot
and can melt at mid throttle. And also
I've seen the capacitor body get super
hot well over 120° C at mid throttle
because the equivalent series resistance
is just too high and they're dissipating
too much heat internally.
And if you see a low ESR marked
capacitor with no visible brand, you
better keep that thing as far away from
your drone as possible. If you want to
go beyond wet electrolytic capacitors in
search of even more performance, we have
to talk about solid polymer. And Unicorn
do a number of ranges of solid polymer
capacitors which are suitable for our
FPV drone builds. The UPL standard range
is becoming really popular because I
Flight are including it with all their
ESCs nowadays.
And solid polymer capacitors will
provide much much better noise
suppression than wet electrolytic
because they've got that much lower ESR.
But they are more fragile and so you
need to use them on ESCs that have a TVS
diode. That diode is going to chop off
any super high voltage spikes and make
sure that the capacitor stays within its
voltage rating.
If the voltage exceeds the rating, the
solid polymer capacitors are likely to
fail very quickly and very very loudly.
But there is a third way, hybrid polymer
capacitors. These combine a solid
polymer cathode with a tiny drop of
liquid electrolyte to combine the
performance of solid polymer with the
self-healing durability of wet
electrolytic. Panasonic, Rubicon, and
Unicorn do ranges of these hybrid
polymer capacitors in suitable
capacitance and voltage ratings for FPV
drones. And if you are looking for the
ultimate in performance and durability,
then these are the ones that I would
recommend. The only caveat being that
they are significantly more expensive
than either the Unicorn UPL series or
any of the wet electrolytics that we've
already looked at. I hope this deep dive
into capacitor technology and a buying
guide has given you everything you need
to avoid the number one cause of
unplanned rapid drone descent in the
hobby.
Let me know down in the comments if
you've got any questions, and make sure
to like and subscribe to the channel so
that you see more videos like this as
soon as they come out.
That's all I have for you for today. So
until next time, I wish you all very
very happy flying.
>> [music]
[music]